on august 9th my house
burned 15 years
of memories 40 years of notebooks
drawings thoughts my life's work
rachel ray's home in lake luzerne new
york caught fire on
august 9th in the years that i lived
here i learned an awful lot
in the few weeks since it burned i think
i've learned
even more today we're going to share
what's left of our home now the
celebrity cook
is revealing the devastating aftermath
the next morning
greg amiot um
the fire investigator put me in boots
up to my hips and in gloves
up my arms and in
a really good uh
quality face mask to walk through the
still burning uh house the 52 year old
talk show host
shared footage of the damage on the
season 15 premiere of the rachel ray
show on monday
this was our entryway it was filled with
paintings and pictures
this melted piece of wall here is where
tony bennett's
picture that he sent me of children
tobogganing used to hang
on sunday she shared a clip on instagram
this was
our bedroom and
our library
and that was our bathroom and our
dressing area
rachel her husband jean cusimano and
their dog bella were not harmed in the
fire
and prior to the accident rachel was
using her upstate new york home to film
cooking videos amid the coronavirus
pandemic
so today we're going to just do that as
a salad last month rachel's rep told et
that they were home when the blaze began
and shared that they weren't sure what
caused it but on monday
rachel had more answers what caused the
fire was simply and we have our
fireplace cleaned
twice a year and our house was less than
15 years old it was 14 years and changed
three is so filled up
it's just just built up in the chimney
the emmy winner also went into greater
detail about the moments leading
up to the fire so i was going to make a
big pasta dinner
for john while he's upstairs changing
i'll start a fire
he'll see the pasta water going the
sauce is bubbling
he'll this will make a nice evening
so john comes downstairs a bit later
and this man comes running through the
backyard
and he's in our backyard screaming and
he's like your roof is on fire your roof
is on fire
that's when she said she tried to save a
few personal
items i ran upstairs to get
medicine my notebooks
my mother's high school ring you know
things that when your house is burning
down you don't want to leave
but when i ran to the top of the stairs
i could hear the fire in the wall i
could hear
electricity i could hear
danger days after the fire rachel took
to twitter to give thanks to the
firefighters who fought to save her home
quote these are the days we all have to
be grateful for
what we have not what we've lost
so rachel how are you doing i'm doing
really
really well john and i uh i come from
the adirondack mountains
we're home uh up in the adirondacks
back in april e.t caught up with rachel
while she was staying in that
home john and i started our own welcome
to our home
and our studio john and i have started
our own little
mini version of watch entertainment
uh here we we are um
the rachel ray show on mondays and
fridays now we're piecing together shows
from
my house and i'm doing a meal every week
on instagram tv
every saturday night so we are working a
lot
for more on rachel ray tune in to the
40th season premiere of
entertainment tonight you won't want to
miss it